as the Sun fades away over an island in
the Okavango Delta the evening chorus of
bell frogs begins in the background the
camp prepares for dock
at nights you need to be very careful
near the water
listen be aware when you fetch water for
your evening wash there's all only the
Predators on land that have become more
active no eyes closed
[Music]
[Applause]
coming together for dinner each night is
a ritual music and laughter serious
conversations and tears an expedition
family
the campfire you can watch it for hours
while listening to the wilderness
thoughts and ideas float into an art of
your mind at peace you feel alive
[Music]
these are the first sounds of the
approaching door
what a wonderful place to wake up after
a night like that nothing compares to
being connected to real life in the
world
you